welcome to the next lecture and the
Shulman lecture series associated with
the physics of dance class the Shulman
lectures are presented under the
auspices of the Frankie program and the
sciences and the humanities it's made
possible by the generosity of Richard
and Barbara Frankie and the series is
named after Robert Shulman right here
who is the Sterling professor emeritus
of chemistry molecular biophysics and
biochemistry and senior research
scientist in diagnostic radiology in
recognition of his roles as a founding
fellow of the Whitney and as an
unwavering supporter of the integration
of science and the humanities
tonight we're honored to have professor
yankee kim here with us she is the Lewis
Bloch professor of physics at the
University of Chicago and I don't know
if I'm in buzzing or if somebody else is
buzzing but maybe I'm okay okay so Jung
key I have known throughout my entire
year career in particle physics she was
one of the first people I met when I
started working on the experiment she
hosted all the young students in her
apartment outside of Fermilab to talk
about science and detectors and physics
every week as she made us pot stickers
that we ate and had conversations so she
was an early mentor for me so it's
wonderful to have her here she also is
extremely distinguished within the field
of particle physics she has served as
the spokesperson for the CDF
collaboration of 500 members she then
served as the deputy director of
Fermilab which is the only high-energy
physics dedicated lab in the United
States so it's an extremely important
piece for her field she's most recently
been leading initiatives at University
of Chicago and also thinking more
broadly about accelerator physics and
supporting accelerator physics which is
an incredibly important part of our
being able to do our science and
something that we haven't been thinking
about broadly enough as a field so we're
grateful for her leadership there one of
the reasons that we've asked yonke to
come and talk to us as a part of this
lecture series is that she does have she
has thought quite a bit about
intersections between science
and art science and the humanities so
she's on the board of the gray Art
Center in Chicago she's also within the
University of Chicago on the board for
the science arts and environment
initiatives and personally she has a
background in dance and with her husband
has hosted salons art salons at her
house for nine the past nine years and
she's had at this point over 70 salons
that they posted at her house
we've asked yong-ki to come here and
talk to us about research and the ways
of knowing as she sees them in the
discipline of physics and to give us
some some physics intuition and tell us
teach us some things our class physics
of dance looks at our two disciplines
physics and dance and how we gain
knowledge in these two disciplines and
the interactions between them we're
excited that she'll be joining our
course dinner afterward and we'll
explore some of those things a bit more
but we're excited to hear about the ways
of knowing and research in physics as
she talks about an atom as an onion and
thank you very much
Thank You Sara that's there was a very
generous introductions maybe I'll stop
here
okay so I'm very happy to be invited is
it okay is it too loud or too soft very
pleased to be invited for this
outstanding program that Sara and Emily
have been doing I've been talking to
them a little bit and I really admire
the what they have been doing I wish I
can do I'm gonna bring pick some of
their brain and I'll trying to introduce
something at Chicago and I hope I'll do
that in the future but we'll see I'll
probably have a more collaboration with
them and perfectly happy help from them
gonna really make that happen
but today's my lecture or the talk is
about a journey in searching for the
most fundamental unit of a matter
we call them elementary particles or him
his talk I would say building blocks and
in to get to understand the building
blocks we need to peel matter layer by
layer as if we repeal an onion layer by
layer to see what it is at the core so
I'm using onion as bio knowledge in many
slides here I hope you enjoy I do i I
didn't so I prepared this talk actually
just for decimals so this is my first
trial see how it goes I may have the
policy if I want to use the same thing
in the future so this is a trial so this
is a really understanding the building
blocks is the main theme of particle
physics this is a field of science
research and just let me say a little
bit more briefly of what we are trying
to do so like what I said earlier our
goal is to understand what the universe
is made of and what holds it together so
this first question is about the
building blocks or as I said elementary
particles and the second question about
how these building blocks interact each
other or it forces between
then to make all of us to make it the
universe so that's the second question
again it's about forces between the
building blocks so I'm pretty sure that
human beings whatever the beginning of
human beings many people have thought
what we are I mean that's how religious
region is perhaps created and and
partially also the philosophy and all
that we are always wondering who we are
and what we are made of what the word is
made of what the universe is made of so
it's nothing any particular question
about particle physics but it I believe
that it has been going on the history of
human beings but the first person at
least who are literally the who really
gave a more thought on the building
blocks is Democritus about 2,500 years
ago as a natural philosopher so to him
universe is composed of two elements one
is atom or atoms and the other is the
void in which atoms exist and move so
atom is a Latin word what it means is
something that you cannot destroy or
divide it so by construction or by
concept atom is the building blocks for
these Democritus and from his view this
is indestructible solid invisible and
homogeneous but there are many different
kinds of atoms of different sizes
different masses different shapes also
to really explain the what we are made
of so for many centuries atoms were
thought to be the most fundamental unit
of matter or building blocks and this
concept of this atom as you know and
I'll say more today so we know that
atoms are not most fundamental particles
or building blocks they are made of
something smaller so so they're modern
physics
modern research already showed many
times that there are something smaller
than atom so it has many changes however
the philosophy of Democritus of the atom
remains the foundation of modern science
so this is again building block concepts
yesterday is building with blocks may
not be today's building blocks but the
concept is there so let me now jump to
our 1900 because for many centuries we
didn't really know the inside of atoms
only around 1900 orbit before 1900
people start seeing something inside so
this will be the picture of Aaron at
least the the concept of atom around
1900 that soon after JJ Thomson
discovered electrons so we know and
scientists knew then that atom is not a
fundamental particle but made of
positively chart and electrons so the
model they had is called the plum
pudding model that means the atom is
kind of ball or sphere but it's very
soft tissue like or sponge-like material
not really solid and there are electrons
or spread out so this is the kind of a
Christmas plum pudding model that's what
they thought it would be so obviously
people want to understand the more about
atom and what's inside and we want to
peel an atom to see inside and the
Rutherford and his team and actually he
has a brilliant to other researchers
working with him and will discover the
what's inside so let me say a little bit
about that this this one is a replica of
their instrument in tabletop
experiment and the showing here so
inside that they have a radium source
that emits alpha particles either
particles are sort of positively charged
the with the two protons in it so those
particles are emitted from this
radioactive material with a relatively
large energy and they fire this beam of
alpha particles to a very thin gold foil
shown here and they so these alpha
particles go through most likely to
their mind and model that I showed you
tip through this fall and land somewhere
there so they were checking where they
really land here or somewhere else but
for the for their mind it's just coming
there because this is a nothing but kind
of soft tissue like a material so again
this is a sort of model they thought of
in terms of atom and alpha particles go
through chip through so this is their
instrumentation here this is there's
alpha particle source to a thin gold
foil and that's what they expected all
the other particles
end up landing here but then what active
Sun is seen is in fact the most of them
land here but once in a while some of
the alpha particles have scattered and
and make angle like that may you may not
see very well the screen so that's very
different from their model but most
interestingly very rare but some of them
once in a while these are per particle
hit here and almost bounced back to you
so this is incredibly surprising result
in fact the Rutherford himself said the
following it was almost as incredible as
if you fired a 15-inch shell at a piece
of a tissue paper and it came back and
hit you so that much of a big surprise
so they knew from this various
experiments they went through that
there's a party recharged particle
it's very small and at the center of the
atom and exactly how small that is they
can tell based on how often they see
particles bouncing back and I said it's
very very rare that means that the size
of this core parts recharge the element
is extremely tiny so this is their view
from these experiments there's an atom
and there are electron clouds orbiting
but inside at the center there's a very
the the massive intense charge of
particle and the nucleus is another
Latin word meaning a small nut so you
can see that that's very small and very
intense massive element in there the
size based on their experiments is about
ten thousand times smaller than atoms so
it's extremely extremely tiny and that
most of all most all the maths our atom
mass is really concentrated on that
because electrons really don't have a
much mass at all very very light
material so you can imagine that's very
very interesting an unexpected result
so around so another interesting part is
that because a nucleus is such a small
element if you look inside of atom you
can imagine this is a boy like at the in
the solar system if you look at it there
the Sun and with earth and some other
planets but in in big picture there's
almost all space is void so there as you
can see they're very interesting
similarity between the inner space and
the outer space and there's a a words
around that time or if after comparing
the size of the nucleus to the size of
atom they're comparing the fly in the
cathedral so if you think a cathedral at
the sides of atom flying Cathedral is a
size of atoms so it's quite interesting
except that or entire Cathedral mass and
weight goes into the fly so imagine that
so now question is whether the nucleus
is the fundamental unit of matter or B
reading blogs well you have seen that
there's something inside Adam
so obviously you cannot stop there we
have to peel another layer to see
whether the nucleus is really building
blocks or not
so in fact that 1932 the discovery of
the patio called a neutron that made a
much clearer that nucleus is not
building blocks but they are made of
something smaller
we call them protons and neutrons
protons are try the particle neutrons
are neutral particles so there are a lot
of studies following these discoveries
of protons and neutrons about the
nucleus what they are and how many
protein the neutrons are included in the
nucleus and what the properties what
kind of energy levels they are so on
surfaces they're tremendously study done
and one of the big contributors and this
the study of the nucleus is the Maria
corporal Meyer who received a Nobel
Prize for her outstanding
accomplishments so this is a her coat
proton the neutron the spin along orbits
like several shells much like an onion
with the many shells so she had this a
knowledge of the onion layers and shells
with how the proton the nucleons might
be orbiting within a nucleus so she got
the nickname the mud the onion Madonna I
didn't know about that until I had
prepared this lecture and I was
searching and discovered the listen so
there was a pleasure so what's next then
so clearly nucleus which is about ten
thousand times smaller than atom as I
said it's made of something smaller
particles protons and neutrons and
indeed there for a couple of decades
people thought that protons neutrons are
building blocks together with electrons
but then we cannot stop killing so we
want to know whether proton the neutral
our building blocks or not so for that
we need to be much better more powerful
the experiments power tools because we
have to see something inside and let me
just give you a brief explanation what
we needed to see something inside so we
I see you and you see me we see around
here because we are using light at the
beam of light to see us and if you wanna
see inside of you we need for example
x-rays to see inside of us we cannot see
ourselves just using visible lights we
cannot see what's going on inside so we
need x-rays as you know very well so now
if you compare them this the lights have
its own wavelength of about a few
hundred to probably 800 nanometers
nanometers is a zero point eight zero
one meter so very small and about the
size of atom and this to visible light
is probably about hundreds times the one
hundredth of your human hair typically
so that's the the wavelength of this
x-ray a bit of a light and x-ray is a
couple of orders of magnitude a smaller
wavelength so because of that wavelength
is a smaller so we can see something
small scale objects and penetrate inside
of your body to see that in in other
words visible they are poles
electromagnetic radiation but light has
lower energy than x-ray so if you have a
beam all the radiations of beam of
particles which have a much higher
energy than their own wavelength is a
smaller so that we can see something
very small scare and that's the concept
so in order to see inside of protons and
neutrons we need a very very high-energy
beam of particles so that's what the
shows that that is that any object if
you wanna see inside deep inside we and
high-energy beam of particles and if you
want to see something even inside deeper
what smaller scale then we need a higher
energy beam of particles so accelerators
do produce a very high energy beam of
particles and let me say a few words
about that
so really modern accelerators were
invented in 1930 by Ernest Lawrence he
was then professor at UC Berkeley so he
the first invention of the accelerator
is about four inch diameter it's the
size of your palm as you can see last
eight and half that case there are many
generations of accelerators and starting
from there and one generation to next
appeared on our the experience and and
the technology we able to make a better
and better accelerators and here are the
most powerful and complex accelerators
at the modern days in today's as you may
have learned or know very well this
Large Hadron Collider at CERN in Geneva
that is the biggest accelerator the in
the world
it's accelerate itself this everything
is underground the length circumference
of this accelerator ring is about 16
miles so you can imagine compared to
what it was to modern days there's
another accelerator at Fermi National
Accelerator
accelerator laboratory near Chicago they
have also very powerful accelerators but
they are not the same kind they produce
a very intense beam of neutrinos or so
what they are planning to make a very
intense beam of a muons and these will
also need be needed to to study who we
are and what we are made of and without
the interactions or forces between them
so not only like a proton and proton
Collider that's Large Hadron Collider we
need other kinds of accelerators to do
this study we also have a very powerful
accelerator in Japan they use electron
beam and it's anti particle called the
positron we accelerate them and have
them collide heads on they also have
Keun beams and neutrino beams and me on
bein dead cetera so these are three
biggest or the most powerful
accelerators for the study of the
particle physics so let me just stop one
moment and just tell you about building
blocks of yesterday and Billy plots of
today as I mentioned for many many
centuries atoms were thought to be
building blocks of everything in the
universe and early 20th century the
discovery of the nucleus now we know
that nucleus and electron they might be
building blocks of the universe couple
of decades later seeing peeling the
nucleus we scientists discovered that
the protons and neutrons are the the
they make nucleus so for a couple of
decades they thought proton Neutron
electrons are building blocks and seeing
inside of a proton and neutron with all
this technology of accelerators and also
are the beautiful and wonderful web of
performing detectors we also know that
they are not elementary particles or
building blocks but they are made of
something smaller
we call them upwards and downwards so
that is still the building blocks that
we know of and we don't we haven't seen
anything smaller than that so the
current picture is a proton the neutrons
they are made of upwards and downwards
proton is a two up quarks and one down
quark and neutron is composed of the one
up Corgan two tankards
so here I show helium atom but if you
look at the hydrogen atom nucleus is
nothing but just one proton and there
are other the elements or atoms
different kind of atoms they will have a
different the numbers of neutrons and
different number of protons therefore
the different number of electrons but
everything is made of a Corgan down
Croghan electron if you think about it
this is a fascinating story all the
chemical elements we know they behave a
very
different but if you really call look
deep down they are all made of the same
thing and then that's remarkable so what
about it interactions or forces between
them we know that again from these
experiments using accelerators and so
and so forth that at the scale of about
the nucleus size or even smaller meaning
that any two building blocks they're
separated by the the scale of a distance
of a nuclear size or even smaller the
dominant forces are weak forces and
strong forces weak forces are
responsible for radioactive decays and
strong forces are responsible binding
courts to make proton the neutrons and
binding them to make nucleus so they are
the fundamental two forces in four over
four two over four forces in nature but
if you had a scale of Eron size then
these forces are pretty much negligible
and and dominant forces are
electromagnetic forces in fact the human
scale dominant forces electromagnetic
forces of course if you go much bigger
the gravitational forces also a dominant
ones so there are four forces in nature
that we know of so let me just quickly
again looking at the size as I mentioned
that the nucleus is about 110,000 times
small and atom and they are made of
protons and neutrons and quarks this up
going down for electrons again with the
modern technology we trying to see even
deeper and deeper but at this level the
size up to about 100 million times small
and atom even if we look at that small
scale we find the quarks and electrons
are still the building blocks whether if
we have a better tools in the future and
see even smaller deeper whether they
still end up the building blocks or not
of course you don't know and and on the
future we can tell us
so you know you are very familiar with
the periodic table of elements these are
all the air of different kind of atoms
and based on their chemical properties
they mean the base or number of a
protons and number of neutrons in the
nucleus
you can make very nice chart of the
table again this is a very powerful the
table in a sense because described very
well it's the properties of these atoms
and I'll just say that is one of the big
accomplishments over the 19th century
but in the 20th century in the in the
physics side as I mentioned the upcourt
are called electrons are building blocks
so the matter which elements are you
pick if you look at it they are made of
these three the building blocks but
while we have a powerful tools and to
see really peeling all the errands layer
by layer and see the inside of the atoms
so be the same the technology and same
tools by doing so we also have a some
surprises and big discoveries made
something that very unexpected I told
you and I showed you that we often have
a create very high energy beam of
particles from accelerators and fire at
a target called for is one of such a
thing and and see what's inside
we also our scientists discovered that
instead of firing at a fixed element if
you also accelerate one beam of particle
and the other one and have them head-on
collisions then we can use the energy of
these beam of particles much more
efficiently so that's why the colliders
are invented again very high-energy beam
of particles and another highness beam
of particles we just collide them then
of course we'll have a lot of energy
available but then Einstein told us that
energy and mass I pivot and that is if
you have a lot of energy we may be able
to create very messy
particle here this famous equation e
stands for energy and M stands for mass
of the particles and and C stands for
the speed of light so when we have a
very high energy we can make very
massive particle based on this equation
these are not ordinary these are not a
proton call electron but these are much
more massive than those in fact these
are very exotic particles we don't see
them in nature in abundance but we
believe that they were there at the
beginning of very early moment of
universe when universe was a very very
hot and high temperature and high energy
because we can conclude that because
with a very high energy accelerator that
we were able to produce them so with the
same concept the energy available very
at the very early moment of universe we
should have as such particles existed so
these particles they are very very
unstable that's a part of reason why we
don't see them in nature in abundance so
they immediately decay with the ordinary
particles like electrons or protons or
pylons and things like that so for other
particle experimentalist so we build
around detector around this area and
just look at them study them first we
identify who they are are the electrons
are they protons are they nuke the
neutrinos and etc and also we measure
their charge there we measure their
energy and so on so forth from all that
measurements of these daughter particles
and we'll be able to see aha there's in
collision time these kind of exotic
particles might have occurred and that's
how we do an experiment so this is when
I started on my particle field research
late 1980s this is the picture of all
the particles created by the
accelerators by the modern accelerators
so let me go through a little on that so
here are the unite
this is United States there's a building
block so elementary particles meaning
that these are all elementary particles
that means they are not made of anything
smaller like a proton or electron they
are all elementary particles so I made
here that area of this disk is
proportional to their mass so as a
comparison this is the hub it looks like
if we make a disk using hydrogen atom or
proton or neutron that'll be how much
the mass it is like and compared to the
others ham pork and tile lepton these
are new elementary particles were
discovered at SLAC National Laboratory
trampo is also discovered at Brookhaven
National Laboratory and neutrino one
kind of neutrino there are three kinds
muon type neutrino by this mass is
extremely tiny it's about million times
smaller than electron so you can imagine
how light that is
was it discovered at the Brookhaven
National Laboratory firmly discovered
the bottom quark which is about five
times the proton mass or hydrogen atom
mass so these are all if you study their
properties its own has a half unit of
spin and we call them fermions so I put
them as red colors the other particles
like gluons gluons are mediators
of a strong forces again I said of
course between course they are strong
forces and gluons are carrying the
strong force they are have spin one unit
spin and we call them spin one boson and
discovered in Germany laboratory called
the Daisy and W and Z bosons
these are force carriers for weak
interactions and they are discovered at
CERN and they also have a spin one unit
and bosons and there are as mass is
about 80 times proton were hydrogen atom
mass and Zeppelin is about 90 times of
that so these are all spin one bowden so
it's kind of intrigued to see that one
type of
particles discovered in American
continent the other kinds of particles
of discovered in in the Europe so that's
what I started I mean let me quickly go
through my experience at least the
project that I was involved in my career
so that's where I started in Japan using
Japan the product the electron poison
accelerator
it's about two miles of circumference of
two miles then I spent a couple of
decades at Fermilab where at that time
there's a proton and it's anti particle
the antiproton they were colliding the
Tevatron Collider it's about four miles
of circumference is this big ring but
there are nine different kinds of
accelerator to make this one so it's
quite complex a system now I'm currently
collaborating on an experiment called
Atlas using Large Hadron Collider
that's a proton and proton collision and
the circumference is about 16 miles so
if you look at the tunnel here in cutoff
then it looks like that so this is a
this itself is this level of size and
and and you can imagine this is 16 miles
long and very very advanced technologies
used an incredibly powerful machine so I
pretty much followed the more and more
powerful accelerators because I need a
better tools so these are no longer
running because they've done their work
done or this crude juice
nice juice already used up so they are
running with a different kind of a
modern technology accelerators different
from this one so they are still very
active research going on and in these
laboratories and different facilities
what about the detector and experiments
in Japan I was the I worked at the
experiment called the ami experiment and
that's my photo and this is a part of
the collaboration and total about sixty
physicists from four countries and you
can see the P
there's a size of detector you can see
what the level of scale of the detector
when I moved to a CDF experiments and
that's myself comparing to the scale of
this detector you can see the how things
change just a front picture you see more
complex and bigger and there are more
people we started off with a few hundred
people collaborators at the beginning
but later on it doubles at the end of
the experiment from 20 countries now at
rest experiment and here you see that
the human being here this person is by
the taller than much taller than me so
you can't also scare that up and it's a
gigantic and and not just the size but
the complexity and and this technology
is a quite advanced so so many ways a
very very powerful experiments it's
about three thousand collaborators from
40 countries but there are many
different kinds of detectors involved
and different physics can be done so
it's not that everybody does exactly the
same thing topics are much broader than
others so I want to mention that Yale
group has a very strong contributions to
both the CDF experiment and Atlas
experiment sara is again it had in
between great job and fantastic major
contribution to this experiment and now
and she was also worked at CDF
experiment 84 so again here my journey
has been better and more father
detectors from beginning to now and
continue so when I look at the detector
so collisions happen from one beam of
particles another in the center of
detectors and as I mentioned these very
interesting exotic particles @ek
immediately ends up with all different
particles coming out so our detectors
job is to really identify each of them
who they are
and and what kind of properties they are
so for for really trying to understand
who they are we want to know how these
particles interact with the detectors
just not one kind of
device may not be able to tell all the
story so we have many layers of
different technology we want to check
each party how they respond to each
layer so in some sense they are also
like onions with many layers so when I
describe detector to people I often say
like I'd imagine onion so here's another
onion analogy and detector also like an
onions so I said this is a the picture
when I started the research and the 1995
CDF and deezer experiment to discover
the top quark this is the heaviest the
most massive particle ever seen it's
about 117 times of the proton mass and
in fact if add up Zeppelin and W balls
and this have become about top commas
and year 2000 they're tau another kind
of a neutrino top that's type neutrino
was it discovered that found that I was
not involved in that experiment but
there's an experiment using the neutrino
beams and they discovered that so one of
the main big questions as you may have
heard from other talks and and from
other the information news that there
was a big discovery happened in 2012
there was a discovery of a Higgs boson
so that is the particle responsible for
giving masses to these particles so one
of the big question to our field is that
yes we measured the masses of these
particles but how did they get that and
and so that's what Higgs can discover
the explain that has been the predicted
for several many decades finally it was
discovered in 2012 this is the pink spin
zero this is a integer unit of integer a
spin but it's that we call boson so it's
not the exactly the same as the other
ones but still balls under still if I
divide the bojong versus the fermions
still Europe just have
discovered all the bosons interesting so
now with all the properties of these
elementary particles whether messes or
charged and spins and all that we can
build a theory so that's the standard
model of a particle physics so that's
the main theory currents here in
particle physics so like what 19th
century scientists have done we also
make a table based on their properties
so there are six quarks these parts of
charge a 1 and negatively charged you
want and there's the three types of
charged leptons like electrons but with
a two more massive ones and there are
very interesting fascinating the neutral
neutrinos that there are three of them
they are also n-type particles of this
one but I didn't put here and there are
force carriers of four electromagnetic
interactions to we contractions or
strong interactions as shown here as
well so when I started that this wasn't
there in and this wasn't there this
wasn't there but the last couple of
decades these are all filled it's sort
of predicted by the standard model so it
has been very successful model and
almost all experimental results
beautifully fit in disa framework so now
the question will be then will you stop
here many people thought that particle
physics is over since we discovered all
the particles predicted by standard
model as if you can imagine of course we
don't stop here how could you write so
that peeling continues but it's not just
because just want to see inside the more
it's it's much more than that and I want
to tell you why we felt that really
peeling these further is isn't necessary
so that is there are many questions
still unanswered by our standard model
of a particle physics or this current
theory for example there are six
kourt's but who said that six is the
right number
could it be four could it be eight but
why so that kind of why question cannot
be answered they have a charge of a some
certain value and who order them who who
said that that value should it be just
so measuring just a charge of mass we
cannot be satisfied we want to
understand the reason behind that there
are if you look at their properties this
one set and another set and three sets
there are the very similarity so we have
a three generations of three families
but again why three there are four
forces in the nature and here at
Standard Model of particle physics
describe three of them electromagnetic
force and weak force and strong force
but if you look at their behaviors at
very high energy particle beams
electromagnetic forces and weak forces
they look the same at very high energy
so we already know that they are not to
separate one but that really come from
one if you look at strong forces they
behave you're also getting similar and
similar to the other two at very high
energy the regime so in other word we
imagine that when universe is extremely
high energy high temperatures at the
beginning and small tiny universe
there's only one force and now as
universe expanded and cooled down not
become four forces a splint four forces
so that's sort of what we have in mind
so anyway that's really true all the
forces become one on earth that's
another big question we when we collide
Potkin particle we produce a same
similar amount of particles and it's
anti particles so that means there at
the beginning of universe again when
universities extremely high energy high
temperature we imagined a very similar
amount of matter particles and interpret
particles there but some reason the
current universe is totally dominated by
matter particles the question is what
happened to those antimatter particles
that must have existed at the beginning
so that's a big question we cannot
and if you look at the neutrino
behaviors they are very different from
the others so there are very exciting
rich programs going on with a neutrino
research and again understanding their
behaviors why they are so different from
others is one thing but we also think
that they might have some clue why the
university is dominated by matter and
what happened to the antimatter is
question so these are kind of why
questions there are other questions if
you look at the rotating or spinning
galaxies this is by the way is due to
gravitational force but if you calculate
the rotational speed a base on visible
objects and visible matter we ain't sure
off very very much smaller than what we
measured so that requires another kind
of a matter about five times more than
our visible matter but we haven't seen
it so that we call the dark matter and
there are very reactive research going
on there as well another question is
that as I said the universe has been
expanding and most of us thought that
now the expansion rate is kind of small
and smaller so slow down or kind of
stable but about two decades ago again
very surprising discoveries such that
current universe it's the expansion rate
is accelerating again this is a very
surprising result and when something is
accelerating that might be associated
with the energy then we don't know what
kind of energy but there might be and we
call the talking as if tendons really
have no clue why could it be we have a
lack of understanding in gravity
whatever that is it is a big question so
if you think about the universe what
visible matter is only about two five
percent there's a huge about 25% of us
about matter we have you don't know what
they are and dark energy about 70% level
we have a last clue and that's that so
things I talked about all
successful successful we are talking
about only 5% of the universe so you
realize that by knowing so much also you
also realize that you don't know a lot
about universal so that reminds me
thinking the more you know the more we
know we don't know again this wisdom has
been there and we just finally agree
with that so peeling another layer is we
feel that we are getting close to see
something another breakthrough at least
answering some of those questions that I
are laid out so we have to continue that
so that means it's not just appealing
more but the more we understand we
deeper we go will have a more complete
and more elegant theory so that all the
questions that can be answered the more
natural instead of just measuring and
put by hands so my journey I mentioned
about that and and we are working on the
experiments at the Large Hadron Collider
this will continue another couple of
decades but any of these project and
facilities very very again to gain
complex that means it takes couple of
decades to thinking about what kind of
facilities are needed whether we have a
right technologies most likely be done
and we have to develop that technology
and build so this is a several decades
of project therefore we have to think
now so we have a lot of activities going
on what might be the future ones so
there are I'm just talking about things
that I directly involved there are other
party neutrinos or dark matter or
tagging is there are many other projects
also similarly going on but I'm just
focusing on the Collider that I am
involved in so currently Japan none of
these things I'm talking about is a
proven this is a still planning or at
this stage and we don't know which one
will be approved by their government or
community yet so Japan has a proposal to
build about
five my long so linear accelerator with
electron beam and its entire particle
path from being and having collision at
the center so it's a north part of Japan
China has a mission of making about
forty miles long circumference circular
Collider they want to start with the
electron positron collisions in the same
tunnel they want to add a proton proton
Collider later CERN in Geneva this is a
Large Hadron Collider country operating
and running sixteen miles circumference
they have a mission of a building about
50 miles going through all this Lake
Geneva that would complicate this
construction of this project but they
have a ambition of building proton
proton Collider or it could be also
electron positron or electron proton
collisions but that's that's in the plan
from us aside we have a bit different
plan instead of going bigger one it's
trying different kinds we never done
before using muons neon particles are
much more about twenty times more
massive than the electron but this one
is unstable so there are a lot of
challenges and we don't know whether we
can build it on ax but that has
attractive the the component which is if
you can make it work we can make it
small with a similar power of the
performance we can make it beam period
even within Fermilab aside so again this
is a long way to go but it's at least
some R&D or research and development
going on so we don't know which one will
happen but we have a lot of plan and the
the research and the development of
technology is going on for future
projects and these are all the global
projects our entire words the community
has to decide together and we have to
contribute to build as one facility so I
mentioned a number of times that the
universe beginning and now we are about
14 billion years old of the universe as
with a small and and expanded and just
very cold that the universe this is a
not scale is not linear so you'll see
that one second either somewhere here
and it's a ten to the minus ten second
here and three minutes and fourteen
billion so we are thinkers human beings
and we have been searching for elegant
and more complete theory so we can do
that by just peeling layer one by layer
one as I mentioned and this is our
current stage of the building blocks but
they might be made of even something
smaller wouldn't be nice that even
though there are six cores and six
leptons but they are all made of
something smaller but despite one kind
of element there would be much more
elegant complete theory it may happen we
don't know so we will continue so this
is a kind of peeling inward but it is
similarly going really peeling inward
meaning we need the high energy the
tools highness beans it's a similar to
we are going backwards so we are peeling
backward in time because we are heading
toward a higher and higher energy or
these conditions which is a part of
condition which is similar to a very
early universe so again more powerful
and higher energy accelerators will lead
us to go even earlier time of the
universe I've got these two are all
connected things we discovered with the
accelerators in this way and then we I
showed you about all the particles new
particles and these particles were
building blocks they make all of us they
are all together make this theory and we
are going after complete and elegant
theory so we will continue to peel away
at the more hidden layers of truth and
and again we believe that we'll find a
more complete and elegant theory but it
is the case with the onion we must
wonder whether they will ever emerge an
ultimate layer where the peeling
most stuff thank you
thank you so much yonke we have a number
of minutes for questions
I am the dance half of the physics and
dance equation that has curated this
series and Co teaches the course those
who have been following the series the
students in our class may feel like
their heads are spinning the last
lecture we heard was on innovations it
in avant-garde dance and here we are now
with a beautiful explanation of research
methods in particle physics I want to
take a stab at making a connection and
comparison with hopefully a question at
the end of it with Yvonne Rainer our
previous dance artist guest we had a
clear image Yvonne in a studio working
alone however with the ghosts of dance
history inhabiting the space and what we
have here are scientists still with that
history working in relation to but with
3,000 collaborators for example in the
Atlas experiment so very different
research scenarios however I believe
both disciplines are engaged in modeling
movement and modeling space finding ways
to model motion and space in very
different scales and what we've bumped
into and thinking about comparisons is
this idea that art somehow invents and
science somehow discovers and that
they're separate and they're different
what I want to ask here is isn't the
standard model something of an invention
it's a nun peeling of a reality of
phenomena as you're observing it but it
had to be crafted and constructed it's a
way of modeling an understanding of mass
movement space that helps you get to
some kind of truth of natural phenomena
so these models seem to me to be
something that get invented perhaps more
then discovered what it's you know
science is different from math in a
sense that doesn't matter how elegantly
formulated if nature does not agree with
that we'd say no so in that sense you
know it's really side by side in some
cases the experiments sort of let first
and and the or the formulas amande
theory come to explain that even that's
a formulating the theory many at this
hour the particle physicists or in
general scientists point of view is if
the theory looks complicated then it's
it's probably not good theory so it's a
beauty of how elegance at the
mathematics form that actually really
has a lot of value so again many the
history has told us that if the theory
looks elegant then more likely correct
one that doesn't mean those elegant one
is all correct of course you have to
test against the measurement so some
cases experiments discover something and
follow the by theory then some other
cases theory form the based on
experiments but theory has more than
what's already the observed but
something else can be predicted by the
theory which explain this one but
something else and then we go and look
for the dead particles so like standard
model many ways is started up by
experiments but then the standard model
theory came about to explain that and
then realized that while I my theory and
our theory explains all the existing
phenomena but something else has to be
there like a top cog and bottom quarry I
said top quark has to be there and hits
again you know trying to understand or
trying to make this whole theory that
explains all the phenomena must have
also expose inthere so that in that case
theory predicted it so it really goes
side by side I would say not
one is you know another pretends or are
out other the art there's no so-called
some fact or truth you can you know
compare against that's different from
science so in some way art you can
invent and I guess audience has to judge
whether this is a great art or not that
might be constrained but it's different
kind of constraints in forming theory I
don't know whether I answer the you are
gonna keep that one I have many more
thoughts and questions but I want to
open the floor for others to to jump in
hi thank you very much I wanted a little
bit more of the natural history of these
particles you know that once we got that
they were up and down quarks inside the
neutron inside the proton different
combinations and and and and then we go
off and we understand chemistry and but
then you said there's more and all these
leptons and all these exotic things in
the top quark and the top quark so
massive it can't possibly be in the
hydrogen it's not sitting around it
right
so where are those things in the world
and and and are they there just to help
you confirm the theory or do they have a
role in the universe are they out there
now are the Higgs bosons in this room
which of those particles is represented
in this room and which of them are not
and sort of creations in order to
confirm the theory and and and do they
have a role in their universe other than
helping you know that your theory is
right yes so certainly you know the fact
a again this the the experiment results
came first you discover things from
experiments even though they may not
exist in nature now so now is so most of
electrons and up coorg and down quark
there are also at the the like a gluons
which
binding quarks and we need another
particle like a w or Z bosons to
understand a radioactive decayed so you
should check that the gluon was much
more massive
well cologne is a methodist sorry honey
grown is massless known at the zero mass
I forgot to make it don't worry and jet
bosons our mess okay so there but there
they were the big big blue gluons rock
your man groans actually it's separate
maybe so but there are there aren't
those bosons a big massive boson is not
sitting inside the hydrogen right that's
correct but if you don't understand how
radioactive materials are DK you have to
have yes it's not that you see things
but we need particles like that to
explain how it decays so we see the
beginning and end radio active materials
we don't really see the W boson which is
an intermediate stage but we need that
to explain and then so so that has to be
again initial final States to understand
that we need something like that and
that pops up in the air' Collider so so
that matches so it's not that always you
have to see it you know it's again those
ones will be also in the virtual stage
meaning that a lot of things we see even
you can think of any particle there are
continuously there's a quantum
fluctuation going on and that
fluctuation of course we don't see them
but those a quantum fluctuation level
all these heavy particles have to be
always created and disappear creator
that always happening to explain the
properties and we require those
particles to explain things we see and
we believe that must be very early
universe as well because high energy
high temperature we can create them and
then our universe has that condition
therefore must be there so that means
that at the beginning early stage of
universe
they played a very significant role to
make what who we are to beyond the
butcher stage that they are here
I think in answer to Emily's question
the if you have a platonic view of the
universe you think that there are things
great things beyond what we see to be
discovered the ultimate pictures models
I think that in in science it's
theoretical high-energy physicists tend
very much to like the idea of
discovering the law as the basic laws
but it's because they're platonic in
their philosophy they think they are
really getting down to something beyond
what we see now there are scientists
also who are very Aristotelian in their
approach who figure that be a sort of
inventing things discovering some things
how they work but there's no ultimate
conception or platonic we are
discovering I think it varies
considerably with the field I would like
to ask you a question
those two viewpoints what is the
information about dark energy and dark
matter comes from space what does that
have to do with high-energy particles
which are very small right so for
example dark matter we you know of
course we don't know who they are but
one great possibility is dark matter
themselves are the building meaning that
elementary particles so if that's the
case Collider should it be able to
produce so we are we have a lot of
searches going on
Dark Matter searches using the Large
Hadron Collider because they have enough
energy and we may be able to produce
dark matter particles so that's kind of
relationship with the particle physics
let me don't get the facts straight
does our information about dark energy
and dark matter
come exclusively from astronomy that
true that observation is there so what
we are trying to do is whether a we can
create dark matter from the accelerators
because there are a lot of theory about
dark matter tells us that that might be
elementary particles may be wrong but at
least that that's how we connect I would
like to ask you if putting together dark
energy and dark matter and with the high
energy particles that you are discussing
putting them together as part of the
great energy description isn't that a
platonic idea as to energy is to be must
be explained and therefore it is the
same thing energy is the same thing and
therefore it is just one subject that
you are study and that's platonic isn't
it because there may be no connection
between dark energy and right so yeah I
agree that we do believe that matter and
energy these are related and this is a
one form matter and energy is different
forms of it it's that's not the question
that's that's there a dynamic but the
question is what what does dark energy
have to do with high-energy particles
particles so for example dark energy
again the many theories believe that
they could be in the form of a scalar
particle scalar field then you clue the
imager again this is a stretching far
but hips is a scalar field so this is
the first scalar field particle that we
ever seen if that energy is also in the
form of scalar field and there are two
scalar fields might be be able to mix so
there might be some connection and not
play
that is right thing but at least some at
the thinking that it can be mixed
between the two so there might be some
relation although if you use higgs field
are trying to calculate a cosmological
constant that's way up and and I don't
think anybody knows about that I like
pursuing these two forms of philosophy
to interpret continually what you're
saying and so isn't it possible that
scale of fields is again a concept that
you have you have from different parts
of work and to say that it would be
universal is a is a conception that is
certainly questionable yeah I can buy
that I came back and you may ask you
know we come up with the current the
theory are there any you start
differently they come up with a
different kind of theory which is
different from and it is totally
possible as long as that explains what
we have seen that could be plausible
that another theory that can explain
again and I think we are going you you
answer the quite nicely to Emily the
question our kind of role and scientist
we are not creating there is you know we
are trying to discover what nature is
telling us and and how to explain the
nature so the in essence invention and
and the discovery might be it's sort of
different concept again we can talk more
at the dinner
yeah interrelated
so they're very very interesting talk
thing thank them two things first just
to comment on dark energy speaking as an
astronomer I think the reason these
things are discovered by astronomers is
because we see their impact only on very
very large scales and so observations in
a terrestrial laboratory just don't
reveal don't reveal the effects of dark
energy or dark matter yet although you
may find dark matter particles at the
LHC my question is more about you know
having been a physicist I think for even
longer than you I'm very familiar with
the idea of elegant theories being
preferred simple theories being
preferred it's sort of and probably
since Occam's razor it's been the
preference at least that long but why I
mean what is there about elegance or
simplicity that is closer to correct
than complexity I mean if we look in the
biological sciences for example it's
extraordinarily complex in fact I have a
problem with biology because if they're
you know why is it so complicated why
does this DNA code for that protein code
for some other protein blah blah blah
why didn't you just make it the way you
want it to be I don't so anyway we have
these sort of different varieties of
science right why why do physicists
believe elegance is somehow closer to
nature and how can we ever tell that's
interesting question I mean even not
even particle physics but some other
condensed matter physics I if you look
at they all look for very vast different
phenomena looking for universality so
one thing that explain all the different
phenomena that that's kind of a pursuing
that it's similar to what we are doing
in the particle physics I don't know it
started with you know even very ancient
you know everything it's a perfect
sphere is value than others so all those
you know symmetries are another good
example we use a lot of symmetry
principle to come up with the theory and
and all that that again again trying to
see
something symmetric means a more elegant
and simple it gives us a more insight
might be you know there are a lot of
tracks historically I mean just looking
at the Newton's law what's happening and
earth to what happened in space with the
same laws just explain both you know
that happened to be also correct in the
sims more kind of our experience and
histories are probably so far showing us
that that looks their way always
so I guess based on hundreds of hundreds
years of kind of track records kind of
guiding us that might be the right
direction yeah I cannot you're better
answer than there but but I I guess in
some sense or some notion or definition
of what beauty is
you know it's it's interesting question
we like to have a more perfect it is
more correct and more beautiful it may
or may not be but that's how we have
been pursuing you to hold humankind's in
some sense right now of course the
symmetry is broken so that creates a
more you know the the rich phenomena so
that's where we are seems like the
nature it's not always where aphelion
symmetry that's what the hips mechanism
and and and in fact it's much more
complicated than then we are looking for
maybe something beyond that and end
simple and we can explain all the
complexity from the more elegant theory